payez vos courses avec la monnaie de
collection qui accumule la poussière
chez vous c'est possible oui parce que
ces pièces on court légale mais il y a
plusieurs mais d'abord contrairement à
notre bon vieux Huard votre monnaie à
l'effigie de l'année lunaire du lapin et
or circulation les commerces et les
institutions financières sont donc
libres de les accepter ou pas mais si
vous utilisez cette œuvre d'art pour
acheter du lait au dépanneur vous allez
perdre au change parce qu'en réalité
elle vaut beaucoup plus que le montant
qui est grabé dessus à la base la
Monnaie Royale du Canada les vend à un
prix supérieur à leur valeur nominale
cela peut être à cause de leur contenu
en métaux précieux de leur qualité
artistique ou de leur rareté et avec le
temps la monnaie de collection prend de
la valeur par exemple il y a 5 ans on
pouvait acheter cette pièce de 20
dollars de la série vestige du Canada
pour 135 dollars aujourd'hui elle se
revendent 225 dollars et ces vieilles
pièces de votre enfance on y retrouve
sur Ebay pour pas mal plus cher alors
oui vous pouvez acheter du pain et du
lait avec votre 10 dollars souvenirs
mais pensez-y parce que ce n'est pas de
la petite monnaie passez le mot
[Musique]